and now the station has changed, it’s
probably hard for us to carry home the
time to experience on the page I want
to live the worst nightmare for the whole
thing that you experienced, and you,
like many others,
wished for a happy life and
please don’t look at me like
I’m almost like that
but fear you
well
[music]
but
you want to arrange a new raid on the grave
now it’s impossible
on the island with rights but they
will start a war put the brigade will start kneading
none of them will have the strength
to support us the
only way out for us to start
collecting the remnants of pouring  you listen to me
with far from all of our comrades
died
this is an incredibly suicidal mission in
order to complete it we need our guys
it’s impossible they don’t want to but we still
need to find them
[music]
take out and love and don’t be mad
at
you for sure  lie to me
you
don’t understand you don’t understand
you look at me and other
creatures of the island as enemies,
we are only afraid of each other
why us because why we are so lonely the
island gave us a chance to create a new
beautiful life and we don’t even try to
take this chance
cafe traitors
[music]